I just never want to talk to the people
I'm on the plane with right I don't hate
them for talking because I get you got
to talk with people when you're sitting
next to them and that's fine but when it
happens I'm always just like all right I
guess it's gonna be one of those things
and that's I gotta deal with it
so I said nah I gotta go to the bathroom
but I got the seatbelt thing on because
you know me dude Johnny plays by the
rules and I'm serious dude you make up a
rule I do the rule I do the rule and
then
if it just so like if I gotta piss if I
gotta go TT on my pants I do it and then
that's on you dude
but the guy next to me that it was about
60. looks at me or maybe 60 and he says
Ah just get up and go uh you people
people do it all the time
and he says that
now
I didn't hear it when he said it I heard
it a few seconds afterwards because when
he said it
all I instead of hearing anything I
smelled
dead bodies
his breath dude it was
a dead body breath okay it was like he
was storing it was like he had a
mortuary behind his lips
I go
I had the same reaction as I would
like you wouldn't have been able to tell
the difference
just outside like inside I was going
through many different things than than
this situation but if I see like a woman
with a body that's amazing or this guy's
smell this guy's breath same reaction
you would notice it in me the same thing
I went oh
same reaction inside different things
are happening but outside you could you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
oh
well this is a Phenom this is a
this is a the phenomenon right
let's go down behind those teeth bud
that's some toe tags in there
skoda
who lives in your mouth John Doe
what's going on dude
let me reach in there pull out a few toe
tags scone on dude hey man would you eat
a live rabbit
so I mean this guy's breath it was like
you'd think oh that that's what
morbius's breath would smell like
he's been feasting on necks all day
and and I go oh and I say all right yeah
I guess so I couldn't shake it dude when
someone's breath smells bad
I can't I can't take it
that stays with me do you know what it
is
assault
right like I have a little bit of PTSD
about someone's if it's that bad I have
pts PTSD about it
I mean I would say for like oh less than
an hour
I can't get out of my head and the
flight was five and a half hours and I'm
like all right well I'm not gonna talk I
can't talk to this guy right if he's
gonna just open up and then
right
so I turned the arrow I did a little you
know the nipple up on the top I turned
the air off the little bit chest thing
so no
floaty smells would come to me
and I go pee I sit down and do it was
five hours
just when my PTSD was about to stop with
the with the
with the toe tag breath just when that
was about to happen
uh
uh again I would just be sitting like I
watched movies and I would just be
sitting and all of a sudden I'd go oh
and I'd look over and I'd realize that
his mouth was open for a little bit oh
oh dude
oh much
thought it was me
it wasn't because I put in mints I even
I was like I know it's on me just for
[__] I'm gonna put in mints I put in
mints still happen dude
I couldn't believe it don't eat toe tax
man it was you know how people have that
lip tattoo where it says like you know
they'll do like this and it'll be like
[__] or they'll do like this and I'll be
like whatever he should have done like
this and it said Mortuary
um
dude it was sub and dude it happened
probably happened 12 times where I was
just sitting there minding my own
business and then all of a sudden
assault and I go oh and I look over
60 year old I'm trying to watch the
[__] 2012 version of Total Recall and
this guy's making it you know it's like
dude I can't even watch the 2012 version
of Total Recall for the second time and
enjoy it because this guy's got to open
his mouth
and give me the [__] business dude
who would have thought that that's the
kind of guy face he had too when his
breath came out I go who would have
thought a guy like you
you just look regular dude alas here we
are
I've been back on my Gabapentin dude so
we're gonna have for we're gonna have
that word recall problems we're gonna
have them word recall problems but it's
all good like And subscribe we'd love it
it really helps us out leave a comment
dude [__] up that algorithm leave a
comment put that Bell notification on
too you know what I don't give a [__]
man honestly don't do it do it or don't
I don't give a [__] man I gotta keep it
real I gotta keep it real man they say
say they say do that it'll help I don't
give a [__] man we got the OG
[__]